-Welcome back, everybody.
We are talking
with Uma Thurman now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Super Pumped:
The Battle for Uber."
You play Arianna Huffington.
-Yes.
-And we were just talking about
that,
and I said, you nailed her
as a character, the voice.
You've got the Greek accent.
-I worked on it really hard.
But, as you know,
great comedians have nailed it
and impersonated her better than
I ever will,
and I knew that too.
So, like, I wanted to -- I was
trying to make sure I wasn't,
you know, making a parody of it.
-Yeah, you're not doing
an impersonation.
-She's a brilliant, brilliant,
brilliant woman.
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, but if I did
Arianna Huffington,
I could do it and be like --
-I bet you'd do it really well.
You want to try?
-Well, it's funny --
-No, but I would do --
-[ Laughs ]
-But it's a character, and I
would be doing an impersonation.
This is acting.
-It is.
-And it's a real person.
-And she's a person.
-Yeah.
-You know. With a lot of heart
and a lot of soul
and an incredible mind.
Like, just, like, doing the
research and listening to her,
she has a stronger
working vocabulary than I do.
And it's -- I expect more
from myself.
I had to look stuff up.
-Yeah, you had to look stuff up.
-Yeah.
-But did you study, like, all
the TED talks and everything
that she did?
-I looked at all the TED talks.
I listened to a lot of her,
kind of, talking spontaneously.
And I was very intrigued that,
actually, she simplifies
her ideas when she has
a planned speech.
-Yeah.
-When she's speaking
off the cuff,
it's even more complex,
the sort of imagery and ideas.
You know, just a really
brilliant, brilliant person.
-Do you want to tell everybody
what "Super Pumped" is about?
The a battle for Uber.
-Okay, "Super Pumped" is
about the battle for Uber.
I mean --
-It's a great story.
-Would you think it was
interesting off the bat?
-No.
-But I was terribly surprised.
-It's a fantastic story.
-It's brilliant.
-It's insane.
-It's kind of like --
you wouldn't almost believe
it was true.
-Yeah, but Arianna was --
-She was asked to go
onto the board.
-Ah.
-And, so, she sat -- she was
the first woman
to sit on the board.
And so, it's like,
a great opportunity,
"Wow, I'm the first woman."
And then it was like,
"I'm the first woman?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Because it kind of went
a little sideways.
-Yeah.
-And particularly around women
and the treatment of women at
the company,
which I think was very painful.
But she stayed there working it
through and, you know,
they tried to correct some of
what they had wrong.
-Do you Uber?
-I do Uber.
But when I finished the book,
called "Super Pumped,"
I did download Curb.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Like, as a New Yorker --
-You have to try everything?
-Well, no.
-Oh, cabs.
-I was in New York. Well, one,
it was like, "Ooh,
this Uber product,
a little bit -- you know."
Just because it has a label
doesn't mean it's clean.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like, the Ubers themselves
are not the sketchy part.
It was more the business
that was sketchy.
But, also I kind of looked out
in New York,
and this has been
on my mind for a long time.
Like, we don't want to see
New York stripped
of our yellow taxis.
-Yeah! We love our yellow cabs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, they should be, like --
they're part of our heritage.
-Yeah, they are.
-So I try to mix it up.
I use different things, but...
-Shout out to the taxi drivers
out there.
-Shout out to the taxi drivers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Uma Thurman
and Joseph Gordon-Levitt
in "Super Pumped:
The Battle for Uber."
Take a look.
♪♪
-The notorious bad boy of tech.
-[ Sighs ] Are you offended by
my "Boober" comment too,
'cause I'll tell you
what I told my publicist --
I'm not going on
an apology tour.
-Offended? Darling,
you're talking to someone
who has had to sit at meals with
Bill Maher
and Pat Buchanan, listen to them
talk, find common ground.
The people who -- thank you --
would take offense
at you crowing a little bit.
Just don't understand.
Every successful person I know
enjoys their success
in their own way or they don't
stay successful very long,
and they certainly
don't feel it.
Now, serving yourself is serving
your company,
which is serving the world.
-Nailed it! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it!
Uma Thurman, everybody,
the one and only.
"Super Pumped: The Battle
for Uber" premieres this Sunday
at 10:00 P.M. on Showtime.